hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
pancreas and this is a overview of
pancreas anatomy and physiology
but in subsequent videos we would go
into the details but
in this video we would learn the very
basic
the function of pancreas the endocrine
and exocrine part so let's begin
so pancreas is situated
just behind the liver and
pancreas is a gland
that means pancreas would have a
exocrine part
and also a endocrine part
if you look at the pancreas it is
anatomically divided into few locations
such as the
assini head neck body and the tail
the tail of the pancreas touches
the spleen whereas
the head and the acinar part is
towards the arch of the duodenum
and just above the pancreas there would
be liver gallbladder etc
now let us look at the pancreatic
structure
now inside the pancreas there are a lot
of
enzyme filled regions which are known as
acini
and from there the enzymes would be
dripping off into a main
outlet which is known as the pancreatic
duct
which meets the common bile duct coming
from the gallbladder
and the liver and ultimately
it opens into the duodenum via the
ampulla of water
so this is the overall anatomy by which
pancreatic
secretions can go and enter the
duodenum now inside the pancreas
there are two broad sub regions
this region is the endocrine and the
other regions
which are forming speci specialized
stuck like structures coming from these
glandular cells these are known as
exocrine part of the pancreas
so let us first talk about the exocrine
pancreas
its function and then we would move on
to understand the endocrine
pancreas now in the exocrine pancreas
there are acinar cells and the duct
cells
these acinar cells if we zoom into it we
would see
a lot of zymogen granules so this
zymogen granules are nothing but
all secretory enzymes which are inside
in inside the vesicles now these
vesicles
need trigger to be released into this
lumen
and we would learn about the trigger
factors
shortly now the pancreatic juice
which is drained down these acinar cells
to the asthma is actually 98
water and other part is generally
enzyme and bicarbonate and the
bicarbonate makes it
quite a lot of alkaline now
here there would be several enzymes
which are secreted such as pancreatic
amylase pancreatic lipase
phospholipase trypsinogen chymotrypsine
in a criminotrypsinogen format etc so
all
major protein digesting enzymes are
secreted
in a primitive format or inactivated
format which further gets in
activated once it reached the intestine
now let us look at the pancreas in a bit
more detail so here you can see
the acini and from there
there would be digestive enzyme secreted
and would be
moving through this uh pathway
and it would reach the intestine now
there would be innervation of the blood
vessels and these blood vessels collect
the pancreatic hormones
from the endocrine part and that acts on
several part
of the gi tract or many other parts as
well
so the hormone is secreted from this
endocrine part
and that is carried by the blood so the
major hormones that are secreted
from the pancreas is insulin glucagon
somatostatin
and pancreatic polypeptide
now let's talk about the phases of the
pancreatic juice secretion
so the first phase of pancreatic juice
secretion is nothing but the cephalic
phase
which is modulated by the vagus nerve
you can see
there are vegas nerve innervation in the
stomach and the pancreas
now whenever there would be some kind of
food in the mouth
or smell etc that would stimulate the
vegas nerve and vegas nerve would
release its content on stomach and
pancreas now as a result
pancreas would secrete some amount of
pancreatic juice
and it tells the intestine to get
prepared
for what is coming down from the stomach
so that is the cephalic phase after that
there is a gastric phase
in this gastric phase the presence of
food in the stomach
modulates the further activities in this
phase and this
phase unlike the cephalic phase is
modulated by
hormones such as gastrin which leads to
secretion of
enzyme-rich pancreatic juice but only 20
percent of
it is released by gastrin alone
now later on in the intestinal phase
when the chyme
is moving down to the intestine from the
stomach it leads to
secretion of cck cholecystokinin
and secretine which leads to two things
one secretion of enzyme-rich pancreatic
juice
80 of the pancreatic juice is secreted
in this phase
and it leads to secretion of bicarbonate
rich
pancreatic juice so which makes the
pancreatic secretion
bit more alkaline so at least at a
molecular level
three factors are governing pancreatic
secretion or pancreatic
exocrine pancreatic activity those are
acetylcholine which are secreted
from the vagus nerve and acetylcholine
receptors present in the
pancreas respond to that after that
there would be secretin
which is also secreted by duodenal and
jejunal mucosa
and it really uh helps
in bicarbonate secretion and also
secretion of the
pancreatic juice and lastly
cholecystokinin
which generally helps in pancreatic
secretion and also it has other effects
on the gallbladder contraction
so overall it helps in the digestion
process in several ways
so i have a separate video on
cholecystokinin you can watch it
now let's look at the molecular level so
secretine
is nothing but a peptide type hormone
secretin binds to the
g-protein-coupled receptor present in
the asynchronous cell
and this signaling ultimately leads to
sodium ion and bicarbonate ion secretion
into the lumen later on
cholecystokinin also binds to its
receptor
present on the senior cells
cholecystokinin
helps in the digestive enzyme secretion
actually cholecystokinin mediated
signaling elevates calcium inside the
cell
which ultimately leads to this zymogen
granule filled up with
enzymes to be secreted into the lumen so
this is how at a molecular level
we understand how pancreatic secretion
is regulated
by hormonal and neuronal ways
so then we talk about endocrine pancreas
so endocrine pancreas means the portion
of the pancreas that secretes hormone
and if we look at the endocrine pancreas
there would be
alpha cells there would be delta cells
there would be beta cells and all of
these different cell types secrete
different hormones and we would get to
know about it
very soon so
first question is how pancreatic beta
cell secretes insulin
so let me tell you that pancreatic beta
cell is the source of insulin
whereas the alpha cells are source of
glucagon delta cells are source of
somatostatin now let's talk about how
beta cells secrete
insulin so whenever there is a blood
glucose level increase
insulin level is high so pancreatic beta
cell
has insulin gene and this insulin gene
gets transcribed and translated which
ultimately forms the insulin
and this insulin is stored in format of
pro-insulin in secretory vesicles
and it is waiting for some trigger to be
released
now when there is some trigger that
means
presence of glucose in the bloodstream
after a meal
then what happens these glucose enters
these beta cells via glut2 transporter
now these beta cells
when the glucose level is low they
remain in a hyper polarized state
so vesicles cannot really be released at
this state
but when glucose level is high after a
meal
then these beta cells goes
in the depolarized state and it augments
it augments the
fusion and thereby releasing of
insulin so the glucose that comes in
forms glucose 6 phosphate eventually
forms the glycolysis
and ultimately it give rise to atp this
atp
actually blocks few leak potassium
channels as
this leakage is blocked now the internal
membrane would be more positive
more depolarized which would be proper
for vesicle fusion and release the
content
into the environment
ultimately insulin is secreted in
response to high blood glucose level
now apart from insulin secretion there
are other cell types right
such as pancreatic alpha cells
pancreatic alpha cells
give rise to glucagon whereas beta cells
give rise to insulin
now insulin and glucagon turns out to be
pretty much antagonistic
to each other and they work in a fashion
working opposite fashion
and their activity their function
are modulated by glucose concentration
for example when glucose level is high
insulin is secreted whereas when glucose
level is low
glucagon is secreted now let's talk
about
what really uh what functions
really glucagon and insulin carry out
and it's a very brief but specific
overview
so if we talk about glucagon and insulin
they modulate several metabolic pathways
and the major majority of them is the
glucose metabolizing pathway so
the glycolysis has opposing effect
modulated by glycogen or glucagon or
insulin so glycolysis is augmented by
glucagon whereas
inhibited by insulin
then glycogenolysis is augmented by
glucagon
whereas inhibited by insulin
glycogenesis
is inhibited by glucagon whereas
augmented by
insulin whereas when it comes to
gluconeogenesis
insulin prevents gluconeogenesis but
glucagon
promotes gluconeogenesis so this is how
we understand
that insulin and glucagon are working in
an opposing fashion
not only in case of glucose metabolism
but in case of fat metabolism as well
insulin and glucagon work in opposing
manner so let us talk about the blood
glucose level again so it would help us
to understand
under high blood glucose level
we would have lot of insulin
right and in that state we know that
there are enzymes in the cytoplasm of
cells which would convert acetyl coa
into melanoid the rate limiting step for
fatty acid biosynthesis
now acetyl coa is carboxylated
by acetyl-coa carboxylase enzyme which
exist in two state
ah active state which is d
phosphorylated and an inactive state
which is phosphorylated
now this d phosphorylation so from this
phosphorylated to d phosphorylated state
is actually modulated by phosphatase
enzyme
and the opposite step is modulated by
kinase enzyme
now when the glucose level is high
insulin actually acts
on these phosphatase enzyme insulin
positively regulate phosphatase enzymes
and thereby
activate acetyl coa carboxylase
now as insulin in in an indirect
fashion activates acetyl coa carboxylase
it augments
the fatty acid biosynthesis process so
moral of the story is
insulin helps in the fatty acid
biosynthesis now we talk about a
situation where the glucose level is
low now in this low blood glucose level
situation glucagon level would be high
and glucagon activates
specific kinase enzymes and this kinase
enzyme phosphorylates acetyl coa
carboxylase
and ultimately inactivates this
particular carboxylase enzyme
as a result fatty acid biosynthesis
cannot
take place inside the cytoplasm so
in short we understood that glucagon
prevents fatty acid biosynthesis whereas
insulin augments fatty acid biosynthesis
so how these pancreatic enzymes are
modulating a biosynthetic pathway in an
opposite manner it's like a switch
now we won't talk about much much about
the somatostatin
in this video later we would have a
separate video on that
but let us summarize what we have
learned so far we learned the general
anatomy and the physiology of pancreas
we learned the location subdivisions etc
then we learned about the exocrine part
of the pancreas which secretes
digestive enzymes and then we talked
about
hormones which are secreted from the
pancreas the endocrine part of the
pancreas especially we talked about
insulin and glucagon
and their functions in controlling
metabolism so
i hope you enjoyed this video and this
video was informative enough if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can also join my unacademic course
by using my code ap 10 you would get a
10
discount if you like this video do let
me know in the comment
if you need any improvement or if you
have any other suggestions
and thanks for listening stay tuned for
more